翻訳: Kento YAMADA
校正: Kyoko Kamura
みなさん こんにちは
突然ですけれども皆さんに
１つ質問させてください
皆さんが今一番感じておられる
コンプレックス
劣等感ってなんでしょうか
コンプレックスといってもですね
様々なものがあると思います
たとえば少しぽっちゃりされていることを
コンプレックスというふうに
感じておられる方も
いらっしゃるかもしれませんし
あるいは 田舎の方言が
思わず親しい友達との間で出てしまった
こんなことを コンプレックスと
いうふうに感じておられる方も
ひょっとしたら
いらっしゃるかもしれません
ちなみにですけれども 私の場合は
この薄毛がコンプレックスでした
私は一昨年まで
22年間サラリーマンをした後に
従来の「隠す」「増やす」以外の方法で
薄毛に悩む人たちに対して
新しい「魅せる」と
魅力の魅と書いて「魅せる」という
コンセプトを提供したいと
そういう気持ちを持って
起業しました「美薄毛研究家」です
今から15年ほど前になりますけれども
昔それほど親しくなかった女性が
SNSで友達申請をしてきました
私はその申請に対して何の躊躇もなく
承認ボタンを押したところ
きっとこんな私のみすぼらしい写真が
彼女のPCのディスプレイに
どーんと表示されたんだと思います
ここ笑うところです
（笑）
お願いします
ありがとうございます！
それでですね
いきなりテキストで—
まあきっと彼女も
驚いたんだと思います
「どないしたん その頭」
（笑）
ここも笑うところです
お願いします ありがとうございます
それで どないもこないもないやろうと
普通の人は思うと思うんですけれども
私はそれを思いつつですね
この「どないしたん その頭」
っていうテキストを
しばし呆然と見つめて
少なからず凹んで
大いにショックを受けました
元々 薄毛であるということについては
私自身コンプレックスとして
考えて思ってましたので
より一層 この事件以降
私「どないしたんその頭事件」って
勝手に呼んでますけれども
（笑）
この事件以降 一層育毛に
勤しもうというふうに決意をした
そんな出来事でした
しかし 同時に自分が元々持っていた
明るい性格っていうのが
どんどん内向的になっていって
挙句の果てにはですね
できるだけ
昔の私の姿を知ってる人たちが
集まる場には行かないでおこうと
そういうことまで
思うようになりました
薄毛をどうにもできない
このままならなさと
その当時の自分を受け入れることが
できないこの悔しさに対して
どう対処すればいいのか
ということについて
まったく答えが見つかりませんでした
ですけれども
対処の仕方がわからない一方で
なんで髪の毛が豊かな人が
しなくてもいい—
髪の毛を増やす
あるいは頭皮を隠すっていうことを
やらなくちゃいけないのかっていう
非常に素朴な疑問が湧いてきたんです
なぜそのままでいることがダメなのか
あるいはダメな空気があるのか
これはひょっとしたら何も髪の毛に
限った話じゃないかもしれません
ひょっとしたら
他のコンプレックスについても
同じようなことが
言えるのかもしれません
私は自分の体験で
日本という社会は
極めてコンプレックスというものに
対して厳しい—
あるいは許容範囲が
狭い社会なんじゃないだろうか
そんな思いを持ちました
ここにですね 私がたった2日間で
女性350人以上にとった
アンケートがあります
これによると 薄毛であるということは
女性から見た場合 交際する際に
決して致命的にネガティブな要素ではない
ということが言えると思います
これものすごい勇気づけられました
（笑）
そして「薄毛の男性は似合ってれば好き」
というふうにおっしゃってくれる方が73%
４人に３人もいるんです
これはすごいことだと私は思いました
そして堂々と見せているのと
隠しているのだと
どっちの方が許せるかという話ですと
堂々と見せている方がいいという方が
ほぼ９割いらっしゃる
そして短くすることに対しての
好感度はめちゃめちゃ高い！
ですね
ですので 何が言いたいかと言うと
決して女性から見たときに
髪の毛が薄いということが
許されないんではなくてですね
隠そうとするということが
あまり好まれてないんじゃないかということが
ここで言えるのではないだろうか
というふうに思うわけです
ご存知の方もいらっしゃるかと
思いますけれども
ひとたび海外に目を向けると
確かにカッコいいと言われるような
薄毛男性はいます
（笑）
これは何でだと思いますか 皆さん
不思議だと思いませんか
同じハゲ、薄毛なのに ね
（笑）
私はですね 薄毛に限らず
コンプレックスといわれるものの多くは
実は その人の有力な個性であったり
あるいは場合によっては
武器にさえなりうるのではないだろうか
そんな可能性を感じ始めています
そして本人はもちろんのこと
周囲の人たちもコンプレックスへの
向き合い方が変われば
コンプレックスという概念そのものが
なくなりさえするのではないだろうか
そんなことを期待しています
薄毛に悩む男性は 薄毛を
恥ずかしいというふうに思っています
そしてその恥ずかしい気持ちによって
とってしまう行動によって
周りの人たちは結果的に
ジロジロ見たりいじったりという
ネガティブな行動を
起こしてしまいがちです
よく 薄毛の男性に対して
「堂々としてりゃいいじゃん」と
「ポジティブになればいいじゃん」
っていう
私からしたら
非常に迷惑であり無責任な
アドバイスをされる方が
いらっしゃるんですけれども
これでは本人の恥ずかしい気持ち―
あるいは 周りの偏見っていうのも
なくなることはありません
ですけれども
これが何かしらのきっかけで
例えば本人が外見を変えてみる
そんなことをするだけで
周りの人たちが受け容れる
そうすると
ポジティブなメッセージを
本人が受け取るというようなことが
起きてきます
するとその変化を感じた人たちが
また本人がさらに
自信を獲得していくというような
ポジティブなサイクルっていうのが
回り始めるわけです
コンプレックスが
コンプレックスでなくなる唯一の方法は
本人と周りの人たちの この両方が
受け容れているという状況を
作るしかないんです
それでは いったいどうすれば
本人と周りの人たちの間に
良好かつ居心地のいい
空気、関係というのを作れるんでしょうか
私は同じ薄毛であっても
かっこいい本人と
それをいじらない周りの人たちがいる
もうこれを作るしかない
っていうふうに思いました
そのためには まず最初に薄毛の男性が
従来の「隠す」「増やす」ではなくて
周りの人たちが納得して
そして受け容れることのできる
薄毛が似合うスキル、ノウハウ
これを マスターして実践することが
大事だというふうに考えているんです
しかもそのスキルや
ノウハウっていうのは
小手先の手法や根性論には頼らずに
科学的な根拠に基づいたアプローチが
必要だというふうに考えているわけです
そこでまず最初にご紹介したいのが
「顔重心コンセプト」
そして「バストアップ重心コンセプト」
というアイデアです
これは 女性の間ではわりと知られている
テクニックですけれども
ポイントをつけることによって
周りの人たちからの視線を
うまくコントロールしていくという
一つの技術です
他人の目線っていうのは
最も目立つ場所に集中する
というふうに言われています
例えば服の上下を分ける分割線の位置
あるいは襟元や胸元に
ネックレスやブローチをつけることによって
相手の視線っていうのは
自在に変えることができます
現に 服の分割線を高く上げる
あるいは高い位置にブローチを
つけるということによって
手軽にスタイルを良く見せたり
あるいは背を高く見せるということが
できるわけです
これを薄毛男性に応用してみよう
というのがここの考え方なんです
薄毛男性の場合は
ジャケットやネクタイ 小物を
うまく組み合わせることによって
印象を大幅に変えることができます
特に胸から上のバストアップっていう
部分になりますけれども
ネクタイやチーフを
派手にすることで
他人の視線を変えられる
コントロールできるということを
私自身も身をもって経験しています
次にご紹介したいのが
「縦横比理論」っていう理論です
これは頭頂部に髪の毛が
ある方にとってみれば
非常に有効な理論だと思います
顔の縦幅は 頭頂部から
唇まで垂直に降ろした距離
そして横幅は 耳を除いて
左右の幅を取った最大幅ですね
これを取ったところ
いわゆるハリウッドとか
あるいは映画スターで
かっこいいスキンヘッド
あるいは薄毛俳優さんは
いらっしゃいますけれども
この人たちの比率っていうのが
軒並み1.2倍から1.3倍あることが
分かりました
それに対して
日本人の薄毛男性というのは
軒並み1.1倍を割り込むということが
わかってしまいました
（笑）
人によっては横幅の方が縦幅よりも
距離が長いという
ケースさえあったんです
現在 非常に真面目に
大阪大学と共同研究を
行っているんですけれども
ヘアースタイルを変えることによって
この縦横比を1.2倍程度にすると
最も印象が良くなるということが
明らかになってきています
写真の左側が 髪の毛で
頭皮を隠していた５年前の私です
このころが1.08倍でした
そして真ん中が1.17倍
それで一番右端が1.29倍です
皆さんからご覧になって
どの写真が最も印象が良いでしょうか
同様に 他の薄毛男性モデルのカット前と
カット後の違いを見てみたいと思います
（どよめき）
感心して頂きまして
ありがとうございます
（笑）
皆さん カット後の縦横比は
1.2倍から1.3倍になっています
私が確認したところ
男女を問わずほぼすべての人から
カット後の方の写真の方が印象が
いいという傾向が見られました
実を言いますと ここで言いたいのは
単に髪型を変えることで
（笑）
周囲の人たちからの
印象が変わるっていうことではなくて
私を含めたこの人たちの
カット前とカット後での中身の変化です
気持ちの変化がすごく大きいんです
実を言うと 薄毛にどの程度
悩んでたかっていうのは
この人たちと私もそうですけれども
人それぞれでしたけれども
皆さんカット後に ご家族あるいは
職場の方々に見てもらって
「よくなったね」とか「垢抜けたね」と
言ってもらえる
薄毛になって褒められることって
あまりないんですよね
ですけど褒められるとすごく自信を
取り戻すことができたというお言葉を
もらったという話を聞きました
実際 職場での人間関係が劇的に向上して
仕事のパフォーマンスが
上がったというお話も聞きます
これまでのように
髪の毛を失う過程で失った自信が
こういう形で取り戻すことができて
そして生きること自体にも
積極的になれるということが
言えるかというふうに思います
私自身もそれまで薄毛で見られてるのでは
ないだろうかというふうに思って
無意識のうちに
頭皮を少ない髪で隠すという
無駄な抵抗ずっとし続けてました
そして そういうことを繰り返していくと
どんどんマイナス思考になっていく
ですけれども
髪の毛を切ることによって
自分の長所や魅力を磨くということに
視線が向いた と
視点が向いたということで
ポジティブなサイクルが
回り始めました
私はコンプレックスというものは
誰しもが持っているものであって
コンプレックスがあること自体は
ごく自然なことだというふうに思っています
しかしコンプレックスを持つ本人も
周りの人たちも
コンプレックスに対して寄り添うことが
これまでできただろうか
そんなことを思うわけです
先ほどのですね
恥ずかしいと思う本人と
周りの人たちの図を
思い出していただきたい
というふうに思います
コンプレックスというものは
決して悪いものではなくて
うまく付き合うことが
大事なんじゃないだろうかと
そういうふうに考えています
つまり本人の恥ずかしい感情と
周りの人たちからの偏見
この両方から立ち向かうことが
出来れば受け容れ合える
そんな可能性が広がっていく
というふうに思っています
そして結果として
居心地のよい空気、社会
そういったものが作れるのではないだろうか
というふうな希望を持っています
恥という感情は
本人の気持ちだけではなくて
周りの人たちが
どう感じているかということも
非常に重要な観点かと
言えるかと思います
さて 皆さんに最初にご想像いただいた—
皆さんがお持ちのコンプレックスというものは
どのようにすれば
コンプレックスを持つ本人と
周囲の人達の両方が
受け容れ合えそうでしょうか
ありがとうございました
（拍手）